I do not see objection the packages
adopted
it was 3 30 in the morning when
representatives of about 190 countries
finally came to an agreement to protect
biodiversity after two weeks of
torturous negotiations in Montreal there
was reason to celebrate we're really
thrilled to see this we see this
culmination of not only this cop but
really years of efforts uh with the
results being a framework that makes
clear
ambitious and measurable goals and
targets coupled with review efforts as
well to track that progress the
agreement pledges to protect 30 percent
of the planet's land and Oceans by 2030
and increase funding for conservation
efforts but some African nations and
environmental Advocates wanted stronger
commitments on funding for poor
countries at stake a million species of
plants and animals which studies say are
at risk of Extinction due to human
activity like farming and fishing
biodiversity loss and climate change
there are two sides of the same coin and
we need Equitable funding and it's it's
just not clear from the framework if
there's new money for conservation
programs another key breakthrough is the
inclusion of indigenous people's rights
as an essential component of
conservation throughout the two-week
conference protesters Brave the Montreal
cold to raise awareness of endangered
species and keep the pressure on
delegates the U.N Secretary General
praised the deal but warned even more
needs to be done
this is not a time to sit on the
sidelines it's a time for resolve
determination
and yes even hope
because despite the limitations and long
odds we are working to push back against
despair to fight back against this
illusion and to find real solutions
Not Perfect Solutions now it's up to
individual governments to follow through
on the agreement and figure out how to
implement it that will involve getting
rid of subsidies that are harmful to
Nature and essentially doubling
Financial Resources for conservation
globally by 2030. Kristen salumi Al
Jazeera